hands it to tremel three seconds two
seconds tremel drives he's found
Darion tremel
will go to the free-throw line
[Applause]
it's all about getting the turn towards
the basket played it perfectly from a
timing perspective let's see if there's
a hit
left arm is down low he didn't hit him
with the right arm left arm might be on
the hip let's take a leather look see
that left hand on the hip
I'm a big believer in that if the
offensive guy
the senior from Marin City California
I was going to say make the first and
miss the second
because you're going to lose on a three
shot anyway but right now obviously he
has to hit this shot
for the lead
San Diego State up by one
1.2 to go